[Musique]
saint zénon à 1h30 au nord de montréal
nous marchons dans un secteur où des
coupes forestières ont été effectués
jennyfer une militante écologiste est
bouleversée par ce qu'elle voit dans une
vision écologique de crise climatique
n'est pas du tout normal de voir un
desarnauts on n'a pas le choix de réagir
on peut pas laisser ce faire les bornes
ya ce sont des infractions depuis
quelques semaines jennifer et les
membres de mobilisation matawinie
manifestent près des chantiers
forestiers les scieries il demande
beaucoup beaucoup de bois et beaucoup de
pression il ya des codes qui sont faites
dans les réserves fauniques dans les
acoustiques puis on a beaucoup de gens
dans lanaudière qui sont très inquiet
d'autres groupes aussi sont mobilisés
plus de 5000 personnes ont signé une
pétition demandant que les forêts de
lanaudière soit protégé dans la mrc de
matawinie 56 % du territoire peut faire
l'objet de coupes forestières
ici chaque année environ 4000 hectares
de forêts disparaissent c'est
l'équivalent de ses militaires et de
football américain pour cette autochtone
qui fait partie de la mobilisation
c'est beaucoup trop c'est en pensant à
mes petits-enfants c'est quoi tu vois à
voir mais qui sera grâce à votre pile
qui sort moi ce que je vois lorsqu'une
question d'argent ou d'une question de
survie
s'ils sont à l'enjeu le principal enjeu
que je vois mme le maire de saint zénon
n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'on se
mobilise contre les coupes de bois
alors que la région vis de cette
industrie depuis des années toutes les
montagnes que le ca a déjà été fait ce
sera tout était fait pour garder
commerciaux aujourd'hui c'est encore
prête à cultiver à cultiver une foire et
se crée aussi une forêt ben oui ça se
cultive en forêt tous les gens qui
travaillent dans le bourg ils font pas
que détruit la forêt ils font pour vivre
et pour essayer aussi de la protéger
parce qu'ils savent que ça fasse en 56
de légende en vie
dans la mrc de la matawinie près de 1000
personnes soit 2% de la population
travaille dans l'industrie forestière
des travailleurs comme réel c'est platon
denilson comprise il faudrait enfin
toutes attentions depuis 24h dans une
mamie là dedans puis spatule s'il
fallait que l'industrie femme si la
caisse parce que hier il n'y a pas
d'autres industries nous parce que dans
cette série de tee shirts et on se
défend de saccager les forêts de
détruire les paysages de la région peut
pas faire ce que tu veux si tu étais
prêt de respecter la loi peu près de 10
conforme et éventuellement des permis de
soi les perdre pour tondre
l'exploitation sur le perdre aussi fait
que le grand malade suite rsa va partout
sur le territoire ont créé les coupes de
bois sur les terres publiques comme ici
dans cette pourvoirie on est au lac
baril toute la montagne qu'on voit ici
c'est dur à dire vu comme ça mais c'est
le plan de coupe qui était prévu
initialement
la montagne il pleut sociaux des plus
aussi à l'est mais j'ai réussi à
déplacer ce plan de couple avec les avec
l'accord des forestiers sébastien
borgeaud se bat depuis des années contre
les compagnies forestières et c'est à
coup de plusieurs milliers de dollars
par année en frais juridiques qu'il fait
valoir ses droits
j'ai l'impression qu'un auteur on est un
peu comme dans les laurentides des
années 50 on pousse à fond la foresterie
il affirme que 30 % des forêts de sa
pourvoirie sont menacés le problème
actuel c'est que le gouvernement
planifie les coupes en amont sans
consulter les gens qui vivent sur un
territoire où qui dépendent de ces
territoires
les trappeurs les motoneigistes les
propriétaires riverains qui ont un
paysage éventuellement les pauvres et
les éclés pas pour protéger une partie
des forêts qui font charmes de la région
les élus de la mrc de matawinie veulent
préserver 12% du territoire créer des
aires protégées
je pense que il faudrait tout repenser
sur 2 oz et puis à louer certains
secteurs à vocation récréotouristique
certains secteurs à vocation intensive
de récolte il faut arriver à la fin
faire en sorte que la forêt on soit
capable de se la partager tout en
respectant les intérêts des uns des
autres
le gouvernement du québec doit présenter
cet automne un nouveau régime forestier